this article of impeachment 48 senators
have pronounced Donald John Trump
president of the United States guilty as
charged
52 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty
the senator judges that the respondent
Donald John Trump President of the
United States is not guilty as charged
in the first article of impeachment
on this article of impeachment 47
senators have pronounced Donald John
Trump President of the United States
guilty as charged
53 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty the Senate
judges that respondent Donald John Trump
president of the United States is not
guilty as charged in the second article
of impeachment
the presiding officer directs judgment
to be entered in accordance with the
judgment of the Senate as follows the
Senate having tried Donald John Trump
President of the United States upon two
articles of impeachment exhibited
against him by the House of
Representatives and two-thirds of the
Senators present not having found him
guilty of the charges contained therein
it is therefore ordered and adjudged
that the said Donald John Trump be and
he is hereby acquitted of the charges in
said articles
you